and I we have Marie from Paris with an
interview
well we're with the king of Rapids
Magnus Carlsen has taken at least that
title not that it means anything is as
far as this woman is concerned but at
least he's shown that he is indeed the
best player in the world and starting
off the Grantchester quite well Magnus
you could you seem to have some hiccups
earlier today you didn't have really
smooth performances and this game wasn't
that smooth either it looked a little
bit unclear what's your feeling overall
as the game was transpiring okay I mean
what do you want me to do so I mean I I
take I take the piece and then I mean of
course he hasn't done anything
particularly wrong of course it's not
going to be lost I mean what do you what
do you want for me
I hope on anything I just what is he
just just getting played yeah but I mean
you're talking about I mean that the
game wasn't smooth and I am again what
do you what do you want me to do I mean
yeah sure oh I mean do you want me to to
get a huge advantage from from the
opening and then to push it all the way
is that the only way you can win a
smooth game with is that your point oh
not at all Magnus but certainly the game
was tricky enough let me get your
thoughts on how yeah but I'm just
feeling that the whole you know the
whole the way or approaching it is
trying to belittle the whole thing
that's my only issue my apologies Magnus
we definitely have respect for you as a
world champion so don't take any offense
to what we're trying to say we're just
trying to do commentary you've got this
out of the way now it's time for blitz
your thoughts on your rest of the twenty
minutes I mean it's it's looking it's
looking ok this sugar is doing extremely
well so it's and is doing well but I'm
also hopeful that I can continue to to
to yeah to win not so smooth game is
thanks so much for your thoughts and
good luck in the rest of the games guys
back to you